by joining us now with more reaction he
is the Executive Vice President of the
Trump organization Eric Trump is with us
Eric by the way I know he has a sore
throat but he still sounds great uh
first
um I'm sorry for what you and your
family are all going through I'm sure
this is painful uh I want to read a
little something from that your father
put out he put it out on Truth social uh
and he said his statement this is
political persecution and election
interference at the highest level in
history from the time I came down that
golden escalator Trump Tower even before
I was sworn in as your president the
radical left Democrats the enemy of
hard-working men and women in this
country have been engaged in a Witch
Hunt to destroy the make America great
again movement now you remember Russia
Russia Russia the Mueller hoax Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine the impeachment hoax one
impeachment hoax two the illegal
unconstitutional Mar-A-Lago raid the
Democrats of lie cheated stolen in their
obsession with trying to to quote Allen
dershowitz's book get Trump but now
they've done the unthinkable indicting a
completely innocent person in a blatant
election interference never before in
our nation's history has this been done
the Democrats Have Cheated countless
times over the decades spying on my
campaign weaponizing our justice system
to punish a political opponent who just
so happens to be a president of the
United States and by far the leading
Republican candidate for president this
has never happened before Manhattan D.A
Alvin Bragg hand-picked and funded by
George Soros is a disgrace rather than
stopping the unprecedented crime wave
taking over New York City he is doing
Joe Biden's Dirty Work ignoring the
murderers the murders the burglaries the
assaults that he should be focused on
and this is now how Bragg spends his
time he says he believes this witch
witch hunt will backfire massively on
Joe Biden the American people realize
exactly what the radical left Democrats
are doing here well there's a lot there
first your initial reaction and your
reaction to your father's statement on
this Eric
what's spot on but my father's only
crime was winning the 2016 election Sean
that's all it was and you know it's
funny the professor wrote a great book
but I leave that book every single day
from the time my father went down that
escalator we got subpoena after subpoena
we would have people like Alvin Bragg
and Leticia James and so many others go
out and campaign on the promise to take
down a person not knowing anything about
them not knowing anything about the
family you have Leticia James who's out
there I'm going to go after his family
I'm gonna sue the hell out of the man I
mean this is these people are evil
they're Wicked and it's why people have
lost trust in the system the United
States of America this is third world
tactics now you have Hunter Biden that
has you know cracked pictures on his
laptop you have Bill Clinton who was
paying Paula Jones 850 000 you have Bill
Clinton who was diddling interns in the
White House in the Oval Office you have
Hillary Clinton who is the leading 33
000 emails while under Congressional
subpoena and no one says a damn thing
about any of those people but when my
father was leading by 35 percent
in the polls and they know he's going to
be the guy that Joe Biden will
ultimately or whoever the Democrat is
going to be will ultimately run against
guess who they go after right up against
the statute of limitations or actually
probably a couple years after a statute
of limitations as a professor said
expired they go after Donald Trump they
will do anything to take man out of the
race they will do anything that they can
to imprison the man they will do
anything they can to harass his family
to imprison all of us they have showed
their cards time and time again again
Sean we didn't get so much as a speeding
ticket before my father went into office
and this is how they treat us every
single day and this is a city I spent a
lot of time with you that is falling
apart I went into literally CVS the
other day and you can't buy Tylenol
because it's locked behind these glass
counters because there's so much theft
and there's so much looting there's so
much homelessness and crime but yet
their attention is going after Donald
Trump little girls are getting shot in
the middle of Times Square
you know what they're doing they're
going after Donald Trump give me a break
you know I know this is a lot on your
family by the way of the 34 alleged uh
charges that they're they're reporting
others are reporting uh I got to imagine
jaywalking and spitting on the sidewalk
definitely the top two
um how you get to that number you know
the scary part of all of this Eric is
when when you look at the long list and
you look at Russia Russia you look at
Ukraine you the impeachment you look at
the second impeachment you look at at
every single thing that they have tried
to destroy your father and I asked your
father in the interview that I had with
him that aired Monday first question I
asked him does all of this help you or
hurt you now after the Mar-A-Lago raid
your father's poll numbers went up they
did not go down what do you imagine the
American people are thinking uh in
regards to this you know we take uh what
is called the non-disclosure agreement
this is probably ten thousand of them
across the country daily a nuisance
lawsuit that is paid because you don't
want to spend year years fighting in a
court and it's taking too much time and
too much negative press it happens all
the time so what do you what do you what
do you take out of all of that and where
is this going to end does this help or
hurt your dad in your view based on
past precedent
Americans are so smart Sean I've seen
this over the last six years I've been
on the campaign Trail they're so smart
and I have to say my father's the
toughest person I've ever met before I
speak to them right before the show and
he is just he's a rock he's a fighter
he's a rock you'll fight this all the
way and we will absolutely win it it's
it's no question about it but Americans
see people like you know Sorrows paying
one million dollars to get out of them
brag elected and then this guy's going
out and doing this guy's you know Dirty
Work people get it you have women again
who are getting thrown in front of
subway trains in New York you have
homelessness that's rampant you have
crime that's rampant people don't care
about this issue they know exactly what
this is again these people campaigned on
video on video saying that they were
going to do this as soon as they got
elected Alvin Bragg brags about it when
he was in the Attorney General's office
that he went after my father a hundred
times he's so proud of that you know
that was their calling card this was
their mission this is what they promised
their donors this is what they promised
Soros that they would do it's why they
received the big checks and it's exactly
why the American people have lost total
faith in the system Sean people are sick
and tired of it they see the
weaponization of politics and of the
justice system we've seen it with the
FBI we've seen it with the doj we've
seen it time and time again at some
point the guy deserves a pass
well Hillary Clinton got a pass Hillary
Clinton of course 33
000 deleted emails no prosecutor
whatever prosecute James Coleman
infamously said uh then of course the
dirty dossier that was used by the FBI
in the 2016 election uh unverifiable
because it was all Bs but yet they
signed four fisa warrants three by Jim
Comey himself that spot on the Trump
campaign the Trump presidency then you
move to 2016 and what do we learn we
learned that in fact that the FBI that
had Hunter Biden's laptop since 2016 uh
that very same FBI that could have
verified that laptop well FBI agents we
found out in the in the weeks and months
leading up to the 2020 presidential
election we're meeting weekly with big
Tech warning them that they may be
victims of a misinformation campaign and
it may be about Joe Biden and it may be
about Hunter Biden again interference
this is a whole new level but again Eric
my apologies you and your family have
been through a lot more of this to me is
a dual justice system this to me is
unequal justice under the law this is
not equal application of our laws this
guy won't even charge murderers and
rapists and and arsonists and everything
else you know he sends every felony to a
misdemeanor in the case of your father
he just makes up felonies unbelievable
and trying to remember one other thing
yeah he's been working on this for six
years this started when he copied a
congressional subpoena because they
couldn't even come up with their own
they looked through 11 million documents
on my father on our company they
couldn't find a single thing
and in the final hours this is what they
do yeah it's so desperate by the way I
bet you Hunter Biden's watching tonight
and I'll tell you this that if you Eric
Trump did what Hunter Biden has done in
his life I guarantee you that the FBI
had that information since 2019 uh you
would be wearing an orange jumpsuit
tonight I'd be absolutely in jail no
question you wouldn't look good in it I
can tell you but anyway seriously Eric
thank you for being with us we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else